university of california will no longer
consider s.a.t and act scores
this is a new york times story they will
no longer taken into account on
admissions or scholarship decisions for
its system for of 10 of 10 schools
which includes some of the nation's most
sought after campuses in accordance with
a settlement
and a lawsuit brought by students the
settlement announced on friday signals
the end of a lengthy legal debate over
whether the university of california
system should use standardized tests
which students of color and those with
disabilities
have said that puts them at a
disadvantage some 225 000 undergrad
students
attend university california schools and
the settlement this week makes the
system the largest and best known
american institution
of higher education to distance itself
from the use of two major standardized
tests
and that's s-a-t-z yeah understand that
there's so much pressure on these kids
right now getting into the right college
is just
unbelievable so you're for this you
agree with you know what here's the
thing if you were gonna test really high
on these
uh it's a bad it's really bad news
because that's that's a golden ticket if
you score what a 34
on your sats you're in anywhere you want
to go basically so i think it's
unfortunate for the kids that can
prepare for these specific tests
but it might be 34 on sat 30 30
go back to the university of miami and
start partying um
so ucla dropped them this past year
because of covid and
it completely changed the playing field
right it just opened up so many people
more people to have the opportunity to
get in there so
i i don't know it's but it's the way
we've been doing it for so long
and it's gonna take a few years for this
to shake out and just see what the
effect what do you think about it what
do you think about it so i guess my
question is what are they using to judge
uh applicants just your gpa and your
resume well that and then what yes your
resume what kind of programs you've been
i don't know about that listen i mean i
get it i get the fact that there's a lot
of pressure to do that but dude
if you can't handle the pressure of
going into college how the hell are you
going to handle the pressure of real
life
what kind of pressure there's in real
life are you kidding me hey you got a
baby you got the pressure
having to put food on the table that's
real life pressure if
you want to get a job and there's a
deadline to it this is too much pressure
isn't college supposed to like prepare
you for real life pressure
what's more pressure being married with
kids or going to college honestly
married with kids is way more pressure
than going to college so for
me i uh i don't know if i like this and
i got three kids one on the way so for
me i kind of want the kid listen
you ain't got a good saturday you got a
good act guess what maybe you're not
good enough for that school
maybe maybe you got to go a different
route yeah but now if we don't find out
and you go to school it takes me four
years to realize we wasted money going
into college
i i don't think this is a race thing
what race
what does this have to do with race if
this is a race thing why are so many
asians killing it in school if this is
truly a race thing
if you go look at the greats in school
with with
nationalities go look at how persians do
in school honestly
go look at our persons doing school some
of the best students go look at how
asians do in school
they're not american they're not white
this is not a race thing
this is the kind of stuff that's getting
a little bit pathetic when they're
talking about hey
it's because of race we have to drop a
ct and sat no it's not because of race
it's because it's tough and there's a
lot of pressure to getting an sat score
i got a real low sat score okay guess
what i realized it's probably not the
route for me i went into the military
that's not discrimination i sucked i
didn't pay attention in school i was
lazy
am i gonna say it's the school system's
fault no it's my fault i didn't
i didn't stay disciplined i lifted
weights instead i went and hung out
instead i want to sold hats instead i
sold beanies instead
i sold baseball cards instead i went in
the military two and a half years later
i got out and i went into sales the rest
is history so for me
to to it's like it's like the whole
thing with boot camp right boot camp is
too much pressure it's supposed to be
it's supposed to be a little bit tough
you're supposed to have a little bit of
a hurdle to go to the next level of a
school
if that's not the case then what becomes
special about going into the ucla system
morale graduated from ucla okay she
graduated from ucla i think her gpa was
like 4.5 4.6 when she went into ucla
you know to me when i see mural you know
what i think about i'm like
salute when she was she got a bachelor's
degree then she
want to got her mba guess what that's
because you paid a price when you were
going in high school others were
partying
you were paying attention in class you
get a salute to getting into ucla now
you're telling me a girl
who busted or tell to get into ucla
maybe got a scholarship for grace that
she had
parents didn't have to fork up you know
quarter of a million dollars now we have
to make her the same as another person
that didn't get good grades
didn't fight for the sat didn't fight
for a cts they're at the same level i
don't see them being at the same level
yeah what's wrong with being competitive
for these kids i don't see a challenge
brother i think we need that
i think we have to depensify the next
generation and we're producing too many
pansies
if we go like this 225 000 undergrads
biggest
so this to me is absolute pathetic i
don't i'm sure you disagree
with this you're right let me just give
you a different perspective i think i
think
you are right that that they shouldn't
just do away with this
but at the same time the ac tiers of the
s.a.t is not an indication
indicator that you're going to be
successful i know a lot of people that
crush their ever say
no no it's different perspective yeah
that crushed their sat they got a 1400
or they got a 32 whatever the numbers
are
and they can't interact with other human
beings and they can't sell stuff
and they don't have a business acumen or
they don't have that they can't
they can't network there's different
strokes for different folks is
ultimately the point
but i don't think it's fair to
unidentify very brilliant people that
would get a sixteen hundred dollars
on the s8 so we're saying the same thing
we're not saying anything
ultimately it comes down to having an
overall resume that's impressive there's
got to be a standardized guidelines you
make it you make it you don't you don't
it's all good go to a different place
it's all gray without something that's a
little bit black and white about test
scores
so seriously you'll never know what
they're using as criteria to let people
in
and if you get rejected they'll never
give you an answer yeah it's like saying
well you know moving forward military
shouldn't look at weight
to get into the military they shouldn't
look at being flat-footed they shouldn't
look at
you're not having 20 20 vision they
shouldn't look at any of that stuff no
you should
you should that's part of going into the
military no no but you're discriminating
against heavy people
you should there are some things like
when
when the when in in sports scene when
antoine walker
didn't get his bonus because he put on
80 pounds
and the celtics discriminated against
him for his weight
you're supposed to do that what am i
supposed to do how are you going to run
and last and play 35 minutes and i'm
paying you 15 million a year 12 million
here
i met antoine walker nice guy we sat
down had a cigar to get a phenomenal
conversation he now represents
morgan stanley and he's trying to help a
lot of athletes not lose a lot of his
money i think he made 130 million
dollars in his career doesn't have a
penny of it
doesn't have any it doesn't have any of
it so so i think there are
some areas i i am not qualified to do a
lot of things and they should
discriminate against me
i am not qualified to do a lot of jobs
and i'm glad they did that
against me not discriminate against my
ethnicity because i'm iranian or because
i'm a syrian or armenian or because
i'm not born in the states and any of
that stuff there are some jobs
that i simply don't qualify for and
that's totally fine
and i these guys are dropping their
standards long term
i've never been a fan of low standards
but that's the direction they're going
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye